merci merci merci alain juste un mot
également est la suite delà de ce qu'a
dit relance ou le revenu universel et
sur les minima sociaux
c'est un sujet bien sûr de préoccupation
je pense que chacun il réfléchit on a
besoin de bien faire la différence entre
d'un côté les minima sociaux et au fond
ce qu'on touche dans la société par
l'assistanat ou le fait pas de soutenir
tel ou tel pour des raisons d'ailleurs
assez différente et on voit bien que ces
soutiens sont souvent dues à des
situations différentes vous avez perdu
un emploi vous avez des revenus de
substitution
c'est c'est le chômage vous avez un
handicap vous avez le droit à une
allocation pour compenser peut-on
vraiment compensé monétairement non mais
pour compenser au moins socialement ce
handicap
et puis vous avez des minima parce qu'à
un moment donné mais comme le rsa ou
comme l'allocation de solidarité
spécifique pour compenser le fait que
vous soyez privés de revenus tout cela
au fond doit être retravaillé avec une
idée de base qui est celle d'une
différence par rapport au travail
c'est extrêmement important et puis
aussi par le fait que lorsqu'on est un
actif et leur feu que l'on a est censé
travailler il faut évidemment que
l'ensemble de la société elle vous
pousse à travailler
elle vous incite à travailler alors
évidemment pour travailler il faut
qu'ils aient du travail
s'il n'y a pas de travail et ciapa iii
censier pas de travail quand le
président au long du jeu mais cinq cent
mille personnes en formation c'est très
très bien sauf que d'abord il sait très
bien qu'il ne le fera pas parce qu'il ne
le peut pas parce qu'on est incapable de
former 500 mille personnes en plus des
600 milles qui sont formés aujourd'hui
chez pôle emploi et puis aux débouchés
ya quoi si à peu de croissance
si ya pas une politique économique
tournée vers l'entreprise avec une
fiscalité réduite ou la compétitivité
est un maître mot le marché du travail
est plus fluide
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de poste et
donc vous augmentez la désespérance du
pays plutôt que voudra sur et celles et
ceux qui cherchent un travail donc tous
ces sujets on doit évidemment les
aborder une société de solidarité une
société d'équité une société de
protection mais c'est une société de
protection qui élèvent et
ceux qui sont en âge d'activité doivent
évidemment être aidé pour retrouver de
l'activité lorsqu'ils ont donc
lorsqu'ils l'ont perdu et puis en même
temps pour évidemment évoluer au fur et
à mesure de leur vie comme nous le
faisons tous en changeant de métier
parce que comme on travaille de plus en
plus longtemps
à un moment donné on change de travail
et on change de responsabilité c'est une
vraie question et on essaiera de la
bordée de la façon la plus la pluie
calmer la plus tranquille possible et
puis la jeunesse un mot quelqu'un nous
disait quel est votre projet pour la
jeunesse
bon d'abord le projet est pas écrit mais
enfin la jeunesse en tant que tel c'est
évidemment lui donné l'envi de retrouver
un espoir et un avenir dans notre pays
s'il enthousiaste quand on est jeune on
n'a pas envie de vivre dans un pays qui
croit pas en son avenir est aujourd'hui
le pays croient pas en son avenir
quand les courbes uniquement montre le
fait que le chômage progresse que la
dette progresse et qu'on trouve pas de
boulot
après une multitude de stage on voit
bien que on peut pas croire en l'avenir
et la jeunesse elle a besoin d'un avenir
fort elle a besoin d'y participer
donc on doit recréer une société dans
lequel on transforme la méfiance qu'on a
vis-à-vis de l'avenir aujourd'hui en
confiance c'est donc beaucoup beaucoup
de sujets en même temps ça veut dire des
études ça veut dire un enseignement plus
proche ça veut dire des entreprises qui
s'ouvre aux jeunes
ça veut dire un espoir ça veut dire des
adultes qui donne cet espoir qui donne
de la croissance au pays et qui donne un
sens à cette à cette croissance
voilà quelques sujets quant à la
personne qui était agriculteur bien sûr
et on l'a bien vu et alain bien raison
les agriculteurs c'est d'abord des
entreprises et on vous doit croire à
l'entreprise agricole france on le dira
de plus en plus nous l'avons dit en
effet beaucoup de propositions dans ce
domaine là je sais bien que
l'agriculture où la ruralité ne se
résume pas à l'agriculture
mais la france a besoin des agriculteurs
et le monde a besoin des agriculteurs y
aura beaucoup beaucoup de bouches à
nourrir sais pas c'est pas ringard que
de considérer qu'on fait des productions
agricoles par rapport aux start up qui
crée du numérique d'abord le numérique
l'agriculture en a besoin
les productions la technologie sont au
coeur des engagements agricole et on
essaiera de le montrer on essaiera de
montrer nos convictions
la force de proposition et bien sûr on
est prête à écouter toute proposition
qui va dans ce sens